welcome to this video this will be a
kibit video and probably a long
one so what am I kibitzing on um yeah
there's the IC open tournament that
um started two days ago on on Friday I'm
doing this video on Sunday 14th of um
April and
um it's it's a tournament with um four
qualification tournaments that have been
played in the last two days and of those
four tournaments both um top placed
finishers so the winner and the runner
up qualified for the final and the final
is today starting in um just a minute
and the final is um very strong there
are eight players playing in um um
knockout
format and of course the big star of
this event is Nakamura who won his
qualifier with 11 out of 11 so pretty
pretty strong performance there um yeah
there are still some other GMS in the
mix I'll be um covering nakamura's games
he's simply by far the best player in
this in this field but if uh the games
are finished or he's maybe let's let say
for instance he's winning his match
probably winning his match not
losing quickly um then I will look at um
some other game from the from the
tournament okay so it should be starting
in um very short
order and Nakamura is playing in the
first round an international master from
Chile um Daniel Maria Zuniga I hope I'm
not butchering this terribly and the
game is on so Nakamura playing B6 yeah
he's often
playing offbeat
openings of course the thing is
sometimes he's doing it a bit a bit too
much and gets himself into trouble but
okay let's see what happens we have um a
modern defense here something like um h
of hippopotamus setup like has F un
shadowed both
Bishops and um then initiated some play
with
C5 yeah this looks um quite okay for
black it's um rather rather
solid but the white of course is um
nicely positioned in the center and has
um everything nicely
centralized so um it should be should be
maybe about equal
aha so we have a nice um transformation
of the pawn structure this now looks a
bit like a a Spanish
opening oh this is
uh this is a nice shot on
E5 so this um now should be should be
better for white he's got the the two
Bishops and
um black doesn't have uh yeah black also
has got two Bishops I'm sorry I I just
uh got irritated by some some messages
here it's a bit bit tricky in my my
window
setup but I hope the recording is is
working working all right
so
we have some exchanges now probably
here and at the end um it should be
should be around equal I
think oh
no there was a check on C5 this was the
was the
problem and this is not equal of course
wide
screen yeah I overlooked the check on C5
and uh this was
a a very sudden very sudden
[Music]
death yeah there's no way out I don't
think
so just um just
goone
yeah he continues resign yeah I wasn't
really sure why so can just just resign
and go for the next game so this is um
as mentioned a knockout
tournament and um they play more than
one game I think it's a package of four
games if I'm not not
mistaken um I don't think that uh they
wait for all round do they wait I'm not
sure it seems yeah it seems like they're
waiting for the other games uh to finish
trying to figure
out how this is
working don't really manage
to can
try can have a look at one game that is
still um
running this is with white John lck
Hammer the number two of Norway still a
strong 2,600 GM against grandmas schrder
from Chile it's very strong Blitz player
played him
recently um yeah Chile again funny
enough okay so what is happening here um
John lck
here white resigns yeah
lost just lost
after after uh no now we now we jumping
here
what I'm following Nakamura here I'm
sorry for the confusion but this is not
uh not a standard that send that observe
that I'm doing here because they are in
a tournament and uh this is really
irritating
me really really irritating me a lot
here I probably uh shouldn't follow kna
this is maybe a
mistake so okay let's have a look at at
this game now for
real so um yeah black is check is a pawn
up but now um white is trying to get get
counter play against the
king it's um a matter of seconds also
this is non increment just three Z
Blitz and
um yeah black will try to try to fight
on oh he just gave away the h
P
check
check yeah this now looks like black
should
win yeah the fcon just promotes now
white resign no way to to stop
that
okay so let's have a look do we have the
second round
going so John lck Hammer lost the first
game here but it's not a a big surprise
Castor is really a really a strong Blitz
player okay okay let's let's see what
about the the second
game okay yeah B3
nakura sticks to his guns playing the
offbeat openings all the
time yeah this it's not easy for black
to to play the H5 was was threatening
and U now black is suffering from a
really compromised Pawn structure with
G6 especially weak so it seems like um
Nakamura is going for Queen F3 or
something or queen E2 and then castling
castling
long okay this this looks very nice for
white I
think yeah just long castles and U you
should be fine okay yeah this is
probably better
even allowing a recapture on F4 with a
knight okay but black um black is not
doing doing too badly and he managed to
get the the king out of the center on
the queen side but white has um yeah
exactly this idea trying to play against
the F5 and G6
pawns yeah now it just threatens to take
on G6 and if you take on H5 there's F5
hanging
so well maybe you can can even take on
H5
first okay so he removed this
pawn and now tries to to cover his
weaknesses but there's Bishop H3 now I
thought Bishop H3 but okay of course
Nakamura is oh Bishop Bishop C4 he must
play Knight D5 and uh this is really
a a bad
pin yeah black has those weaknesses F5
D5
maybe Knight E2 to D4 is also an idea
okay this is the the more direct way to
go with Queen to E5 and
F5 Queen to E5
yeah and you pick up
F5 okay Knight F5 this maybe Rook
E8 but you can take on F5 with the queen
yeah this is the simple
one
now I need to be a bit cautious here
right then then then this may be some
counter
playay night C4 he will see
that
now but white is is a bit a bit weak
here the dark squares and so on it's not
a completely trivial technical
task but yeah the the problem is for
black is that the B6 Knight is such a
bad piece it cannot go to A4 or C4 and
in general it is hard to give this piece
any um any decent role and um oh Knight
C5 Knight E2 covers Queen C1
made still some tricks
here so um probably
um white um has everything under control
but still needs some some cautious
cautious
play
yeah Rook takes E2
what why not Rook takes
E2 Rook takes E2 Queen C1
made this was very lucky for
Nakamura very very simple black was just
winning for one
move okay so we continue and it's still
not clear I mean black black got a pawn
back and has got the Rook on the second
second rank but um there's still this uh
terrible Knight on
B6 so white is um still better okay he's
doing a good job here getting getting
some counter
play you would need
to somehow magically transfer this
Knight to
B4 but uh yeah there's no magic in this
game
yeah
Knight
probably and it
promotes yeah this is
gone yeah the the point was really
surprised because this was was really an
easy tactic look at this just Rook takes
E2 black forfeits on time
y
can I do this I need
to some of these games
are why I don't have the
what I cannot make those arrows for
whatever
reason
why
ah oh wait wait wait just wait I'll I'll
manage I'll
manage I needed to to to change
something n now I'm now it's it's all
right again so I can I can really show
the it was was very quick to here
here black just just can take on E2 and
Nakamura resigns basically this is this
is
made and the strange thing is that he
played Queen A3 to threaten this I
thought and
uh here it was was was parried
but here black uh black forgot about it
again and this this is just winning it's
still um still an attack also
okay but
um let's uh
look at an actual game they already
started the new one sorry for some
confusion here it's u a bit different in
tournament so again we have this
[Music]
B6 B6 stuff and it seems that uh also
the white player didn't prepare anything
because Nakamura is known to to play
this B6 stuff and white obviously
doesn't have anything in store if you
prepare a little bit against this it's
it's simply not not particularly good
for black but okay so we have um a kind
of a French position now where black um
managed to get the bishop on A6 and yeah
this is a nice
Bishop but um should be quite okay for
black
now and of course the standings is two z
um in favor of Nakamura now a bit lucky
after the last
game but uh okay if uh the white player
wants to stay in there he needs to um
needs to win now no nothing else a
draw qualifies Nakamura for the next
round of course he's a huge um huge
Underdog but but anyway need to try at
least
yeah this is the problem this bishop is
sitting very nicely on
C4 and how is white
um going to make any
progress well it's difficult H H3 and G4
is about the only only possible idea
that um white can come up with but um
you always okay this is funny oh and a
good plan yeah you just
um he just um transferred the king to B7
to to make it safe yeah
here white tries to get play against
F7 yeah maybe
F6 yeah I think white is struggling here
it's um it's difficult now what to do
with the Knight maybe you can go Knight
H7 but this
looks really weird Knight F3 you can
just take and take on E5 if if not uh if
there's not anything
better oh wait one thing I I didn't I
didn't tell of course this is not just
for fun this is um a real money
tournament um I would need to look it up
I think the total price fund is
$4,000 so first price is probably
something like 2,000 or so it's I'm just
guessing here I would need to to look it
up just just a
second
4,000 I know the first first price is
850 okay second price is
550 ah so I see there's 4,000 um oh
funny Checkmate there's 4,000 total
because there are some rating prices for
under something groups okay so check
made at the end okay this was a pretty
um easy of all Victory because the um
yeah the player here from from
Chile um probably living in Spain yeah
Spain flag Spanish flag um he missed
this win in the in the second game and
of course it's it's very hard to come
back from
that so Nakamura through let's um have a
look at the other games there's still
John lck against Castor
running so what's happening here yeah
John lck is much better in this game and
he's check is he much better
check yeah he is much better because
it's made I was just trying to figure
out how the standings in this uh match
are can I see this here
standings oh yeah I
can so this was necessary CA was leading
with the or Sher is the real name Castor
was leading with two Z so John lck
needed to win here
also through is um so we can uh try for
the last game of this match um where is
it yeah here so John lck um as black
here needs to win this game to stay in
the match and um go
to yeah I think some sort of tiebreak I
don't know um they probably play
additional game or something or a sudden
death game I don't know would be
interesting to see I didn't I didn't
read the exact um thing okay
so it's um Spanish Spanish game started
with the the Berlin variation and um
Castor played uh the D3 line the the
Slow line and black certainly doesn't
have any any problems here he um I think
equalized um comfortably here question
is can can you can you do
more white of course has um a good
Center so um you might say why equalize
yeah there two
Bishops and uh or in this case we have
got a
simplification but um there's
um not much I think for black to to
worry
about got the bishop on F7 potentially
going to
C4 and um yeah white
took lots of space here which
is good most of the time but sometimes
you um yeah you're mostly weakening
yourself I'm not sure that this is so
great what white uh did here of course
it's just a three minute game so it's um
everything's uh also matter of of quick
moves I can tell all kinds of things
here when if I play three minute chest
it's usually not looking too great I
just need uh need those two
minutes um compared to a five minute
game I mean I simply need the time in 3
minute I I don't play don't play so
great at least uh without some some
constant practice okay so there's some
maneuvering going on and um it's not
easy at all to make any progress oh I'm
surprised White's really doing something
I thought you would just stay basically
and uh don't do
much he could have taken on e4 maybe it
was very quick Rook takes E5
oh yeah it's it's difficult it's three
minute
chess white is uh very loose yeah look
at look at the king position so maybe
there is something that uh black can try
and I think he had some chances but
maybe he played a bit too
quickly there were maybe some tactical
shots at at E4 or E5 I don't
know wow Bishop takes what's the point
maybe he just clicked the C Pawn or C4
was
terrible Rook takes E5 or this yeah wins
a
piece Che Queen takes Rook E2 yeah so
check to to all white resign yeah kind
of a sudden sudden end to this game I
like black but there wasn't
so much happening really so we have
um uh two two um two to tie here to all
and um probably some kind of uh
decider not sure
how there's uh how they decide to to do
it okay we can
oops
sorry can uh a yeah two TI games between
those two this
nice so we get lots of uh interesting
interesting chats to to
watch um what else is
there yeah probably um they set up the
the deciders deciding games now um I
actually tried to play in this uh in
this qualifiers I played two of the
qualifiers but um I didn't do too well
in the
first um first three or four games and I
I lost against at least on paper
relatively weak players and there was
one game especially where I had some
cheating suspicions so I I basically
stopped stopped the video and um and and
called it quits after 20 minutes or
something I don't know I was simply
feeling that it was Something Fishy
going on I didn't play well but um it
was it was weird one or two games and I
tried a second time um yesterday but I
simply was too tired I I played so badly
I was playing without doing um doing
comments just just on my own so to say
and um I I don't really um I don't
adjust well to the 3
minutes okay so let's look at this
tournament um yeah there they're
currently setting
up the the tiebreaker I
guess maybe for this I can follow one of
the two players so make sure that the
game is uh is popping
up
oops so who is Nakamura playing in the
in the next round can we see that
somewhere let's have a
look aha he's playing the winner of
um some other
match who is playing in this other
[Music]
match uh some ofm from from India Gambit
101 and the other one is an I am from
yeah
from from Brazil a very
International very international
field all right so I'm not quite I'm not
sure ah I see okay now they're setting
up
the the
tiebreaker there was still this uh one
game going
and
uh okay yeah Nakamura will
play against in the next
round against this Roberto junor burito
Molina from Brazil
MH Okay so first here's the
decider three tie uh two tiebreak
games so we have um oh B vinck
variation don't see that too
often nowadays in three minute chest
this is really
funny both players
um playing uh all kinds of theoretical
moves now B4 and now Rook B1 or Knight
A4
A3
now A3 is the the
move but
uh
wow yeah now black can play all kinds of
moves I'm I'm not sure Knight E5 yeah
this
one this is also a line Knight C5 now I
think but uh now I'm I'm done with my my
knowledge
I don't know this is a very very hard
opening to play anyway and in three
minute
chess I think you need um need to really
trust your your instincts and your your
calculation ability in special
especially as black if you play this um
in a three minute game as your King on
B8 is wide open okay but you still have
some pieces around it of
course
yeah super complicated Rook E2 maybe or
is this too
much taking F2
H yeah what
else do you want to give up F7 yeah
probably this is
right yeah white can check on d8 but
it's just Rook C uh just Bishop
C8 now you need to protect this uh
probably anyway yeah and now of course
white cannot exchange yeah he must avoid
the exchange because then the C and D
Pawn are just too
quick black is trying to exchange Queens
if you manage this you're usually uh in
good shape with your with your big
pawns this is really an avalanche of
Pawns A5 maybe
A4 and so on I don't know but
um yeah on D4 very complicated yeah
keeps the pressure on F2 yeah this is
maybe good uhuh black repeats yeah he's
he's down on
time maybe he feels
that yeah I don't
know yeah probably he felt he's got
better chances with
white Maybe
but um I don't know black black seems
good to me I mean these pawns C and D
pawns look dangerous okay let's um
continue yeah I followed John Ludwick
here so the we this at black hope you
don't mind so a Four Knights
game Knight D4 now probably or D6 no
yeah this is not the kind of opening
that
uh should
um um frighten black too much but it is
of course
solid very solid
um from the white from the white
side yeah but uh okay this is now very U
nice for Black's got two
Bishops and uh nothing in particular to
to worry
about
yeah he's trying to put some pressure on
the
center maybe bishop D7 Rook E7 something
like this oh no this is also good
yeah the queen is nice on F4 good
move Bishop takes H3
yeah hey I spotted a
tactic Queen F6 and back yeah black is
the pawn up now
good position
check Queen
A2 the greedy man's move why he took it
it's probably all right I mean but it
always feels a bit weird to go on
those those uh trips to the side of the
board to grab a a Mega
Pawn okay but Dwight doesn't really have
any any big big play it seems at least
at the
moment oh this is nice Rook D4 Queen B3
yeah so it seems that white is falling
apart
now
check oh so I don't know if I would have
done that but okay two pawns it's
probably
winning
yeah black should win two pawns
so yeah well I don't know I mean I I
really have problems to to to play this
three Z but if you ask me if you spend
if you play 40 moves and spend only one
minute on them I think it's just playing
too quickly as wi but okay I lose on
time all the time in this time
control
so what should like do maybe get the
bishop to D4 this would would be my
try trying to put it on
D4 it's not completely
easy it it should be winning but um it's
not um so self-evident how to do
it then the pawns on F7 and and so on
also not
easy
so he's trying to to to get the pass
pawns with H4 this is probably a good
idea Bishop to G3 maybe and then try to
advance on the queen
side a yeah
okay now he's to protect yeah this this
should be winning now three pass pawns
is um is usually too
much
yeah but the white Bishop is uh is is is
holding them
all can black um activate the
king
check
yeah black him now now he
tries tries to activate
check why not King F4 I don't know why
he did
that now he's got no no no Pawn to
attack maybe black cannot get the king
out out of out of there but it it should
be winning now can't believe
that H3 yeah now this is too much the
pawn is on
H2 now you can just push the a pawn
also the white Bishop is just just just
overloaded
or
B5 yeah um black is down to 15
seconds yeah you should put the bishop
on f8 and then Advance the
king yeah okay he will manage this is uh
quite resigns so big comeback here by
John lck winning winning this um against
um Castor
here he uh was down with by by two
points and uh still um came back yeah
maybe um Castor should have tried to
continue this
um continue this binck this binck line I
don't
know difficult okay so we are looking
forward to the sem finals
now and um
I'm start again with
Nakamura and as mentioned he's playing
this International master from
Brazil maybe they uh need um
couple of minutes to uh set this
up in the metime I can try
to do they uh actually refresh
this oh yeah they
do so I pull up part of the website here
you can see here the here's
the not 14 final it's more like the
semi-final we can see that um here
Capilano brid this is Nakamura playing
against
um Roberto
GBM this International Master Roberto
junor Brito morina Molina and the other
semi-final
isoni this is grandm zonan from um
Armenia against John lck so um very ni
nice okay
so do they make oh no they continue I
thought they would maybe do a small
break or something but uh thankfully
they
don't so here we go Nakamura playing
again the B6 opening against Roberto GBM
and U I'm not quite sure why Naka is
always playing with the Italian flag
recently okay so we again uh go
to the hippopotamus setup and he's
playing G5
wow H KN
D4
yeah it all looks a bit um a bit fishy
for black but it's not not easy to to
break down of
course yeah the the bishop is probably
going to C8 at some point it's U really
an ugly piece on
B7 um yeah it's I think I think there
um
oh oh I don't know maybe this wasn't B
before was weakening C4 not sure if this
was was such a great
idea but uh it's still not easy for for
black to to find some
um active um
play the problem for black is he cannot
really move any of his
pawns you cannot take on D5 and now he
can play F5 and Knight B3 was was a bad
move I think you need to control um E6
and F5 he wanted to prepare this but um
now black is is getting
active look at the two Rooks on the F
and defile they are now really playing
and um white should have prevented that
and now the E4 is just hanging I
think wow okay it's completely messy I
probably don't understand this
position all kinds of stuff is hanging
now
check
h i wonder about Knight G4 or Knight C4
or moves like this attacking
um attacking
E3 I didn't do
that yeah black is probably better with
the Bishops whites Knights whites
Knights are not uh so
great yeah I predict that white will
lose material in some way because it's
just not they're not working and know
this there's a piece
gone okay this was lucky lucky
prediction but somehow White's pieces um
didn't look too too too great in terms
of
Harmony only uh slight issue is that
Black's King is a bit bit bit
Airy but um Black's got all pieces
nicely positioned near the king so oh
now he even got Queens off probably I
know he has this check
okay yeah white can resign
basically there's no no play at all yeah
he
resigned yeah usually um Nakamura is
just just stomping those regular kind of
IMS good Blitz player it's like I mean
probably this guy let's have a
look yeah he's R rated 2402 so so just
about my level and if I play Nakamura I
can score the occasional very very
occasional draw and I win maybe one out
of 50 or so because course he's just not
paying
attention but um usually he just eats up
uh those
guys not really um Without Really
investing much
effort
okay so the next
game yeah he's he sticks to his B3
stuff nice it's healthy you can you can
play like this why
not okay probably
avoiding all kinds of
pins could have played um the other
Knight to D2
probably yeah it's about equal I think
this position if I'm not mistaken
um in the last year the first um edition
of this tournament I think Nakamura
played this um um GM simonian so II is
the name or aroni I don't know how to
how to pronounce that um who currently
playing the other semi-final against
John lck so maybe we get the the same
final he won the first game against John
lck but
okay he came back um in the round before
so um let's have a look at this game um
it's it's um an equal
position just um nothing much
happening Rook d8 yeah Black's got the
Rook on the defoul white only has a very
uh symbolic Advantage with um the three
against two on the queen side in some
endings this is a factor but here with
black controlling the
defa um it's it's
nothing
really in a tournament game I'd rather
be black
here
yeah because your king is better King is
playing and you will not be able to play
B5 C5 is hanging
so black is better
now he's playing with an extra
King yeah the question is
um how do how do you make this is a very
direct move move not sure if this is
correct ah playing for tricks again yeah
black must
Retreat well I don't think that
um A5 was the right right way to
play maybe it was better
to to prepare oh but now what about The
Rook here The Rook tra maybe how does
The Rook get out of there with F5 King
F6 F5 King F6 The Rook is
strapped but how do you attack it to win
I don't
know yeah tricky
again
maybe Rook
A6 Knight C6 something like this yeah he
really has uh oh now he gets the a
pawn but the Rook is out of out of it
now at
least so black is just the PA up oh now
now it's a rook end
[Music]
game yeah this is um draw Rook end
game but of course Nakamura is much
faster so um it's it's just the
draw I wonder if he would accept the
draw if uh I don't have any sound here
check Che so I didn't have the the
window
focused I wonder if he would accept the
draw here I don't uh don't think so
check
check check yeah there's not much that
um black can do maybe here with F4 need
to go F4
buddy check to have at least
something
check check oh Naka is actually offering
a draw game drawn did didn't expect that
really yeah no no chance I mean he's
just just too quick just too quick in
the other semifinal um it was um in the
other
semi-final simonan is leading two Z
again against uh John lck so he's
probably going
through so here it it was a bit lucky
maybe for Nakamura around here with no
later here with with the trapped Rook
there maybe was something of course hard
to hard to say with the little
time so we have the oh no with D5
now
so
um it was
[Music]
um yeah bit of a Hipp hippopotamus style
but then he played
D5 and now black has casted
long yeah what now maybe take it Queen
C6 six something like
this yeah whites oh this is a weird move
why would you um kill your bishop and
give um give black the F5
Knight yeah black is fine now I would
prefer black now at least in a Blitz
game probably um in any kind of time
control but
um those uh those Knights are always
dangerous check
yeah King B2 probably don't want to do
that but what black wants to do is
exchange the knights yeah this is now
this is now excellent for black You've
Got This brilliant Knight on F5 against
a completely idiotic Bishop on
C1 black is much better now especially
if you consider that you can can now
exactly sometimes I slip a German W in
there Rook d8 exchanging Rook and now we
have got the Knight and queen combo to
attack the
king and
um this is um very very good now for
black simply don't exchange Queens of
course the ending also um is bit better
for black but uh you
want the The Mating
attack
chances
maybe thought maybe
C5 white is weakening himself
even yeah maybe you can transfer this
Knight to
D5 well now you can take and queen F3
yeah winning a piece okay this is also
good
the other one uh was a piece he's
playing too quickly I mean he's winning
anyway probably but
um he could have win won a piece
so Queen A2
maybe yeah it's a terrible position to
play with the the king out in the
open
check yeah the King on C5 it looks like
there should be maybe Queen
A3 not sure why he didn't take the pawn
okay there's the another Pawn I
understand okay now it that's H4 also
gone so
can I can also grab
F4 maybe Queen F1 covering A6 and then
Queen
B5
check
okay
so Nakamura is leading this match by one
point if he wins this game he
advances
check oh Queen A2 looks like C6 check
King C5 Queen D5 mate hey I spotted a
mate come on C6 check King
C5 Queen D5
made and now he looks at this for one
minute and then he plays it or what
yeah I don't know hard to understand him
sometimes okay so in the other in the
other match John lck won so he's still
in we can um look at this game next
because Nakamura is just for whatever
reason letting the clock run down and
then uh we'll give this
mate um in the other game in the other
match John Ludwick has the chance to
equalize
so I'll switch to that
soon oh maybe is there some connection
issue
[Music]
okay so uh what is happening
here
oops okay I'll do a reconnect
here and
uh not quite sure what happened
there so okay I guess he he he won this
game with the
mate I don't know what
happened okay so this is the this is the
last game of the semi-final probably
John Ludwick needs to um win with
black and um it's again um um a
Berlin and
oh for some reason simonian
um sacrific in exchange here I don't
know
why black is just an exchange up for
Pawn check with
uh I don't know why doesn't seem to have
any um any compensation for this
yeah and now C5 and you have a bad
Bishop on B2 yeah John lck is winning
this he's
um maybe um equalizing again coming back
from
two I mean on zero against two being
down two
games
maybe intending to play on tricks on the
on the bishop but mostly keeping the
pawn on D4 to make sure that the Knight
on D1 and the bishop on B2 are are those
stupid
pieces
yeah this looks good Rook F28 I think he
played this really well keeping control
of the position maybe there was some
computer star moves that are better but
he really kept um kept everything nicely
together and made sure that this Knight
on D1 and the bishop on B2 stay
bad
I don't know maybe yeah maybe Queen E5 I
was thinking about this getting rid of
the
queen trying to to win the win the end
game ah maybe this wasn't the
best Bishop B6 black is better but it's
not so it's not clear if he can
win
yeah
yeah no this wasn't wasn't so
great but black is 30 seconds up on the
clock almost 40
seconds so
um he didn't even get get another
Pawn oh yeah here black must be careful
white is now coordin ating well
again Knight takes D5 there was Bishop
for yeah okay this this white cannot
lose but this is the kind of the kind of
position where it's clear that it's just
a draw should play with increment but
with one uh minute and uh couple of
seconds against 30
something black can of course try to um
play for a time
win and um
yeah yeah he's down in the he's down in
the match so he needs to um to try this
it's not uh great
yeah it's just it's just dead I
mean in a 3-1 or 3-2 game they can uh
they can agree to a draw oops he blund
up the
bishop white
resigns yeah okay 13 seconds he would
have lost some time probably and this is
um why 01 with no increment is uh
tricky okay so what does this mean we
have um a tie again here so John L
coming back from being two points down
and
um we have a
decider two um additional
games to decide who is playing Nakamura
in the final
yeah John lck Hammer here the black
player will
also take part in the First Norwegian
super tournament ever to be played in um
in May one of the strongest tournaments
in recent times it features all the top
players um with the exception of kumnick
Who Um can canell the event he simply
had too much on his plate and
um I think it's it's a bit more
complicated than just this simple
sentence but um they managed to get a
good replacement in Peter swidler was
always um yeah a person to uh yeah nice
to have around in a tournament he's uh
always very nice to the public and
explaining his games and so on so um a
good replace obviously a very strong
player being the six time Russian
Champion okay oh sorry I'm a bit late
here with the game okay so the first
tiebreak game and uh it's this um
what was ah was some some offbeat line
here and it looks like um white is
winning
already I mean in a in a tournament game
um John lck would win this game I'm very
sure he's he's a pawn up on the queen
side in a kind of a bko structure but
black has zero counter playay because
the knights um completely cement the
queen side and black has um no um no
Pawn
break whatsoever while white has this F4
play yeah just Bishop F3 and now you go
Knight C4 Rook C1 E5 and black is um is
destroyed
he's got
nothing yeah it's a shame I missed the
first couple of
um first first couple of moves um it
simply wasn't showing up
here so e D6 and queen
D2 E6 E6 Queen D2
maybe pinning the Knight and D6 is
hanging this looks also
strong H yeah it's not so clear I think
um white um lost a bit of the threat
here he's probably still good but he had
a position which was flat out
winning and uh this is I don't
know
it's still
complicated now c4 is hanging yeah wild
spoiled
this he was completely winning it's it's
a
shame I always like to see those crappy
play like just uh tossing a Pawn on the
queen side for nothing always like to
see this punished so bit of a shame here
but he uh he simply opened up the
position too quickly with some
um some preparation moves look here in
this position before you go E5 you can
you can do all kinds of moves to improve
your position yeah and um and win win
easily yeah black has no play and he
played this bit too a bit too too rushed
and now he's he's even um yeah he's not
is he he he what down something no but
Black is Black is very active and A4 is
hanging yeah White's pieces are not um
coordinating
now and black has an excellent Knight on
F5
yeah so um it's an end game but black
has got an extra pawn and the much
better
pieces white has no coordination
whatsoever Knight D4
maybe and look at the the Knight on A7
it is
uh
this m yeah B1 is M check mate yeah this
was this was bad I mean white was
uh was winning here right out of the
opening and
um and he just played this too quickly
probably thinking you every move wins
maybe it does but um it's it's it went
awfully wrong okay he still has the
chance to come back there two
games and uh he did come
back quite
uh quite a number of times two times
already he came back from being two
points down and he needs to win with
black
again so uh this line again and
it's quite funny that he placed this in
a must-win situation it's black it's a
very very safe uh line of course but uh
it's not
um the kind of stuff you usually want to
play if you want to win the
game yeah so it's um probably around
equal
here white can simply develop and um
have
um a good healthy
position yeah just Knight D2 Rook E2
stuff like
that
yeah white is um maybe very slightly
better
here he's controlling the eile and um
very hard to imagine um how black should
should win this game I mean he must win
the game
it's uh a draw means he's
out yeah it's it's it's very drawish
actually black can black
can expel The Rook on E7 and
uh yeah and always um a PO on the
eile yeah probably needs to try that
just just Rook E8 and not now but um oh
there's Knight G6 he blund at
this
oops yeah this should be a should be the
win for simonia here yeah probably
um
the the first game was
um really the the problem I mean here it
was was equal and so on but very
difficult to play for win but um John L
really needs to win the white game it
was it was just
winning okay so couple
of more moves but
uh n no there is nothing I briefly
thought thought maybe the the a
pawn is uh is is something but um yeah
no no way black can can win here the
Knight is on the edge and trapped
basically maybe this is a draw
yeah yeah but okay black must win this
is the problem it's
um white um spoil spoiled this in a way
to a draw but the draw is of course
enough to
advance yeah there are no Miracles
possible
here yeah now white white goes through
with the G Pawn but it's it's it doesn't
matter black needed to to win and uh a
loss or or a draw is um basically the
the same thing so it doesn't really
doesn't really
matter so we have got a final and this
is uh grandm simonian against um
Nakamura
Nakamura certainly being the favorite in
the final but uh I think this this guy
here he I think he played last year in
the final if I'm not mistaken and U as
is not bad at Blitz
obviously okay so um I'll make sure to
follow
Nakamura and I wonder if they um they do
a small break maybe
because
um there were so many games now in a row
for uh for simonia for aroni
here maybe maybe they do they do a a
small
break I look here maybe there's some
[Music]
information
yeah it um takes um couple
of seconds anyway to to get this set up
I believe and then we'll see the final
um by the way is um six
games not four six
games and um let's see what Nakamura is
coming up with if he plays uh this B6
and B3 stuff all the the way he did so
last year he played B6 all the time and
got in lots of
problems U okay we still won it
though yeah probably they um they going
for a small break so I'll briefly pause
the video as well and I'll return When
the the game is
starting oops I had a small delay here
and missed the first 20 seconds of the
final okay so we had one
B3 uh again indeed and uh it transpose
into some sort of King's Indian
attack which looks
um
yeah which looks like white maybe is um
slightly
better it's got this
um nice Pawn on E5 which cuts the board
in uh in two
halves Knight f six check this is the
move that white wants to play at some at
some
stage yeah well white is white is um
nicely positioned Black's got bad the
bad piece on C8 especially he needs to
improve this night
badly but not easy at all to to make any
any progress
oops he just blundered that one it
happens yeah why is just um up material
now this the
on yeah and the the problem is it's the
a pawn the a pawn in connection with the
bishop on G2 always spells big
trouble it's probably um close to
promoting
maybe Rook B8 now
[Music]
activating Rook
B8 or Bishop F1 Bishop F1 and then A6 I
don't
know Bishop B7 is also
move yeah black can can check on A1 but
it's not leading too
much and white can take
it and if he re recaptures Bishop
H6 okay white is winning in various ways
now this is uh probably this this is one
of
them
check F7
maybe
or yeah everything wins can also just
move
um I was thinking King G2 but this would
have blundered with Bishop C6 this is of
course
better
check yeah this is um an easy solution
you just need to get uh the bishop on on
the long diagonal and um
promote wait Rook A7 now we still have
to play
this this end game this is not hard to
believe yeah okay white white is too
quick with with the King on E6 I don't
believe that black is able to to hold
this but of course this wasn't necessary
at all far too
complicated
probably shouldn't take E5 now no not
allowing King
[Music]
E7 I don't see a win really
check I mean a win a win um besides
winning on time this is is this a
draw
check yeah this is a
draw a clear draw
now
yeah but this is why 30 is sometimes a
terrible time control I mean Nakamura
really played from a plus 10 position um
he really played terrible to spoil this
and now he's uh going for for flag
win of course they can play very lots of
moves in this time
maybe no no 50 moves are not
possible black needs uh still 20
moves 20 moves um and he doesn't
manage 20 moves in
um in this time he cannot play and he
also needs to press the press the draw
button
black forfeits on time yeah this is
uh this is uh Y3 is a crap time
control and um well okay of course you
can can just offer a draw but not if
you're
Nakamura okay so let's see what uh how
it continues he won the first game okay
he had had it completely in the back I
mean he was uh
around
here check I mean every move won
basically he he really made it
difficult just U I don't know King G2 or
whatever I mean black is is completely
busted okay so next
game and we have this uh
B6 opening
again
yeah I'm not sure what white is um what
white is doing if given the chance I'd
always put a Pawn on
C4 but um this is of course also a
matter of matter of
taste
I'd also like to always like to have a
Pawn on C4 to just get
um get more
space so white should be slightly better
with better
space but uh it's not not nothing
special
yeah black has um taken the chance to
take on F3 spoil the point the pawn
structure but white has um two
Bishops and um it's not um easy to see
um how
black should
uh make any progress
here yeah I like White's position but
it's not U easy to um to do
much okay maybe he shouldn't have
allowed
that to um to get into this isolated um
Pawn
position but maybe it doesn't matter he
tries to drum up an attack on the
king
Knight D7
here yeah this is an
exchange it's still um really messy
position
so it's not clear it is so terrible that
black loses the exchange Che he's got um
got decent pieces of
course yeah it's more the attack here or
maybe Rook takes H5
now and then you yeah and then Rook G1
and so on maybe it's it's an attack I
didn't calculate I just uh thought that
this might be might be good yeah oh this
looks strong Bishop takes
F5 check
check
check what is this material wise it's
white is a porn down you if he
takes Queen E6 he
defended black um somehow defended this
it looked really
terrible maybe there was something it's
hard to hard to tell in in with so
little
time yeah white um has an extra Pawn but
it doesn't really matter
much oh Queen B4 Queen B4 won The Rook
ah now black has this counter play with
the with the
pawns the b and a
pawn yeah it's probably
draw it's a bit tricky for
black
check check yeah it's it's it's probably
a draw at the
end what's the times
equal
check and Nakamura had offered to draw
check
which is silly of course I
mean white has got more time and now an
extra
Pawn now black is um very active
though now he blundered the
P what a
shame
check
yeah black is
um black is better now with with the
with the better not it's not better but
he's the one to to try with the H
Pawn Yeah I need
to need to sa at one point and then it's
a draw yeah the pawn is um game is
promoting a draw at the end maybe
uh most likely there was something for
for AR Boon in this but didn't
manage it's um it's it's simply a very
very fast time control cannot
uh expect a perfect
play okay so be3
again so now was still
leading and uh he had problems though I
mean this the he won this on time and in
this game with black he was much
worse so this is probably um transposing
into into
grunfeld when white um is playing
C4 oh he doesn't I know he
does
so it's um green fold type of
position white will probably Retreat
this
Knight at some point oh black is um
trying to open up the position um
instantly yeah the question is can white
take on D5 play E4 but he he didn't do
that yeah this is probably around equal
hard to believe that um one side
should should be uh better or maybe
black with Rook D2
now it's still complicated all kinds of
stuff is
hanging Bishop A3 maybe well hard hard
to
do
yeah can E7 is saying so I need to play
Rook C7
first yeah it's complicated E7 is as a
liability and you can take on C5 now
twice but there's E2 and A2 hanging so I
don't know maybe black is still okay or
not still okay it's probably
better
so A2 or or or E2 I don't
[Music]
know so Black's got two Bishops and B3
is looking somewhat weaker than
uh interesting
move
Bishop f8 yeah probably
check and at the end of all this there's
E2
hanging and now Black's got the two
Bishops yeah yeah simonan is playing
really great here I mean he's playing
Just much better than Nakamura but it
didn't help up to
now
oops so um
he um won
this won this pawn and it's an extra a
Pawn Plus
um yeah cannot take A7 because of the
mate plus you've got Bishop against
Knight and this bishop is is much better
than the Knight the knight's um
notoriously bad against flank pawns the
a andh
Pawns
so let's hope that
um AR is winning this just a matter of
once in a while the better player at
least in this match yeah not saying he's
he's a better player than Nakamura but
he's playing better in this match that
he that he will win
this white resigns yeah there's a82
coming so he managed to level the the
score it's it's one and a half one and a
half after three
games so we've got a really exciting
final
here ah not no B6
anymore
so uh we have
a Berlin again now by
Nakamura yeah black must um make sure to
um to play with the D Pawn play D 5 to
develop the bishop this is why he played
C6 and Knight
E8 yeah white has got lots of pieces in
the direction of Black's King so this is
um interesting way to
play
yeah Queen H5
maybe and what does black do now maybe
you need to retreat yeah there there are
lots of tactical shots in the
position I don't think for
example I'm not sure if you could play a
move like G6
here yeah Nakamura is spending uh
a bit of
time Queen H6
yeah Queen H6 this looks very
dangerous Knight takes E4 now Knight
takes
E4 what is this Knight takes
E4 isn't this just a winning huh Bishop
E5 Bishop E5
yeah this is nice M on H7 and uh Bishop
takes F6
so
check but is this a mate check Bishop A3
yeah
and ah Queen h8 yeah maybe it's a piece
is this a piece I can't
count Bishop E7
now okay Rook E4 you've got um some
extra pawns yeah two extra
pawns so great great uh great play by
white yeah people people in the chat
accuse him accusing him of cheating the
white player but uh I think uh if a
computer would have made it simply and
uh and it's not too difficult um if you
especially with the attacking moves it's
I spotted most of of them as well and
then it's not not too
difficult okay so it's
um two extra pawns and uh White should
win this after that it's difficult for
Nakamura to come back he needs to win
badly
then funny funny funny little trick but
you can even take it I
think C2 Rook
C5 and now Bishop D1 it's still a
winning uh a winning end game maybe you
had something
easy
check yeah just uh just take it and win
the the end game it's
um
A7 is is also
gone black
resigns yeah great stuff here Nakamura
really losing badly in this game maybe
the Berlin wasn't the wisest Choice here
but okay you're
always hindsight is always
2020 so Nakamura being down a point and
uh remember he won this uh silly game on
time so um okay we are we are to the
non- theoretical openings again and he
really needs to win this everything else
is not
acceptable so King's Indian um
attack with the colors reverse Kings
Indian attack and it's it's like the G3
line with colors reversed the king's
indan yeah Knight C6 there's Bishop C5
so you need to get get get to some other
Square
yeah Knight coming to D5 this is
nice yeah maybe oh A3 don't know why I
expected um to put something on
D5 with this
um chance missed I think black is good
now
yeah black doesn't have any problems I
think he's got space advantage and uh
why doesn't have any
uh particular great
idea
yeah C3 is um a point of
attack some someone is uh is uh writing
that probably there's not the playing
but uh but
aronian country country made of simonian
of
course yeah I don't know I mean I think
um Nakamura had problems with this guy
last year already and one very um
narrowly
also so what is this it's um materially
equal here but C3 is very weak black can
actually take it
check
I Black's King is uh is very weak and
maybe the maybe White's got something
now yeah queen queen to the eighth Rank
and then maybe Rook G7
H
check yeah Rook D7 uh he really let him
in there so this looks very good for
white
now there's especially Bishop D4
threatening
now yeah maybe Queen E7 just keeping the
pressure
on
yeah black Bishop D4 is is is a problem
King h8 you also Play Bishop
D4 black is defending this really
well okay Queen takes there a rook a and
GF there's I don't know
E3 I don't know maybe E3 uh G7 is M
sorry of course you need to defend the
mate
first
okay yeah Queen G5 and Bishop D4 I'm I'm
really amazed that black is still
standing here in in some way at least
continuing to
there's Queen G5 threatening now with
the maid Okay so we've got a final game
with um equal standings two and a half
against two and a
half a final game uh simonia and aruni
will getting will play White against
Nakamura playing
black and uh The Winner Takes it all in
this game in case of a draw we have um
have a decider of um two
games yeah we had this uh structure
before
yeah we as mentioned we had this before
why has got somewhat better pieces and
maybe maybe he's trying to get something
on on the
king but um certainly you cannot um
sacrifice on on G6 or something it's is
not possible and Nakamura managed to get
in C5 and uh Knight to B4 is an
idea yeah black looks
okay the two Bishops are are very nice
now on G7 and
B7 and um black is trying to play on the
queen
side while it's not so clear what white
is doing maybe yeah he's regrouping to
get get the bishop on oh no I thought he
would play Bishop
A2 but uh he didn't uh didn't go for
that yeah the good plan getting the
bishop uh the Knight on C4 as black
exchanging E5 or just getting the piece
on a good Square it's very nicely
positioned on
C4 yeah okay my guess is that
um nak kabura will will make that it's
it looks like a good position for
black nothing nothing clear I mean I
don't see something clear here
but um black is
um black is in good shape he simply's
got the the more active
pieces yeah white has no no concrete
plan can basically just uh just Shuffle
black also can think about playing E5 at
some
moment regrouping for Queen H4
maybe or queen F6 something like that
yeah I think this uh is really nicely
played by
Nakamura he manag to push um him
back
slowly and now he went into an
ending not sure if this was the best one
not sure at all but um okay how to how
to
um to assess okay he sacrificed the pawn
even but um not sure what what's the
point of this
oh this this um probably white should
should have
avoided okay um but it looks like we got
opposite colored Bishops
or Knight takes A3 Bishop takes A5
probably a
draw yeah iaboni was offering a draw but
it was was
declined yeah I think that uh draw is a
fair result actually
check
okay we are in for another Fleck flag uh
fle
race it's a it's a dead
draw and of course Nakamura will play on
time again with 40 seconds again 24
seconds oh now he offers a draw
very rare he's usually just uh as unfair
as they come but um he offered the draw
here okay so three against
three um or three three
all and uh this means two additional
games in this
match and uh this video is getting very
very long we are close to two hours
now and of course you don't need to to
watch it all
if you manage this far without uh
hitting any pause button then you're
really a tough
person
okay King's Indian attack
[Music]
again
I think this is exactly the same as uh
as
before somehow it looks a bit shaky for
black like you're not very well
developed but
uh probably white has no way to to
exploit
this
yeah white tries hard to keep it
Complicated by Bishop H3 instead of
um exchanging on
C6 yeah I I much prefer black here just
just space
Advantage yeah white has a very nice
Knight on C4 but black has the center
and potentially a very good
Bishop
yeah
there goes the
Knight yeah maybe it um it goes all the
way to B7 but not sure what it is doing
there yeah Knights are always tricky in
Blitz as it
um was mentioned uh and I'm not quite
sure by by uh by whom but uh it was the
saying as long as you have a knight in
uh in in Blitz chess you you don't
resign yeah okay black um somehow lost
the B5
pawn and now C5
H yeah Knights are tricky in Blitz
it's just um it's just like
that so it's an extra pawn and white
having the better
structure he just has this two Pawn
Islands against
four I'm trying for Bishop H6 and E3 but
okay Knight C5 how do you protect E4 now
probably you
don't yeah white
uh White is winning but Nakamura was
winning before in other games with plus
11 or whatever plus 10
I don't know the evaluation but lots of
uh material
up and uh here he can just pick up G6
and so on the Knight on e4 defends F2
there's no counter
playay black
resigns okay so Nakamura won the first
tiebreak game and
um the final tiebreak game coming up now
maybe the final game if uh Ari wins it
then uh we have a continuation
even all right B6 again
yeah
for some reason he keeps playing this
with Bishop F4 I don't
know
okay yeah I think I still think it's
funny that Nakamura plays such an
opening when he needs to draw but okay
it's it's just blit chess
what um can you
say
Knight C5 I thought would be maybe an
idea oh this is so quickly I don't know
what's happening
here Knight
C6 yeah now B5 and G6 is hanging yeah
they played this so quickly um I cannot
I cannot do any comments on
this I need at least the bit of time to
to figure out the position and they're
just playing too
quickly yeah maybe white trying for
Knight D4 to E6 putting pressure on this
Pawn now yeah white probably doesn't
want to exchange or he does I thought he
would Retreat to E4 this this looks
um better for black if you ask me the
bishop on G3 looks a bit silly and U
black has got a very good um post on
D5 let's say Rook D5 now or taking and
uh a knight to D5 maybe
later and also there's King G6 F5 and so
on I don't know maybe it's just equal
but white needs to win this game doesn't
look
um doesn't look like um White is coming
close to to win here
yeah black is better
somewhat with the King being more
active Okay transformation now C7 is
hanging so black
um yeah maybe just take F6 or you can
cover C7 and try to pick up F6 for free
but this looks weird Okay
E5
yeah the question is is the F Pawn a
strength or weakness maybe Rook f8
intending King H5 yeah picking up the
pawn yeah King H5
uhhuh King H5 King H3 this is
funny
yeah well no way that white is is going
to win this
ever maybe he can go all the way to
B7 it's
not maybe bishop F4 G5 now
now need to need to
calculate King
C6 B4 take it and A4 H I don't know this
this this is an a
[Music]
pawn I don't know the a pawn it's very
dangerous how do you do you stop the
pawn
maybe this is uh
saving but but
uh yeah Bishop D2
now now this was the only way to draw
probably
and the C
Pawn
wow it's just it's just a draw
by by have one tempo
yeah
so it's no no way to to make any
progress
only black and blunder the queen or
something check but um it's it's a draw
check
check check
check check check
check
check game dra yeah now this is a
repetition but uh it's an unavoidable
draw anyway with Perpetual checks
probably so that's it the end of this
tournament Nakamura as we could uh
expect before indeed won it but uh Aron
here Grand Master Simone put up a tough
fight
and if you ask me he was even dominating
not dominating but being he was more was
actually the better player in the match
if you ask me he just lost one uh one on
time but Nakamura played in a dead draw
position on time but um he he did did a
good job here um now Kamura won all the
other Mages um convincingly though yeah
this was a very long kyt video I hope
you enjoyed it was um one of the longest
videos ever in this channel but um if
you made it this far you're you're tough
thanks for watching and I'll be back
soon